[Applause]
i'm not gonna lie yo
i'm being a hundred percent serious when
i say this
i [ __ ] love indians bro i thought you
were unique
no son it's a billion of us
i'ma trade your ass for the your girl's
dad bro oh he's the greatest
yo he's the greatest
son i got this girl's dad is in the show
okay
my gosh these girls in the show archives
family show this dude
is so [ __ ] funny he's hysterical
your girl's sister is one of the
characters she's like the sweetest girl
right she's so [ __ ] sweet yeah
there's some monsters on this show right
she's not one of them she's so sweet
yeah
truly does want to meet somebody find
love excited
didn't you her daughter which i
appreciated didn't show the daughter at
all
she was married before had a kid yeah
didn't extend work out
she's looking for love you got to meet
the pops who's involved kinda
right and there's an indian matchmaker
woman that's coming all the way from
mumbai
right to hook her up with a dude yes
she shows her a dude she's into the dude
and the dad not having it not having it
and she goes but dad i think we should
just go look and then the dad says this
and there's no disrespect to the accent
obviously this is just me trying to do
the best he goes
he goes he looks there he goes he goes
no no no we don't want you to commit
another blunder
don't commit a blunder has been said in
my household
minimum a hundred times after hearing
that
literally after i busted on my girl's
back i was like babe i don't want to
commit another black dog
my favorite part is when he's asking up
why the guy got divorced and he's like
not cool with it yeah
and then he says was his ex-wife
american or indian she says america and
he goes
ha ha now
i know what he [ __ ] up now i know he's
not good enough for my girl
but gotcha it's hilarious because his
daughter is also divorced yeah
he's judging the [ __ ] out of this dude
for being a divorcee with a kid
but 100 he gave me the same treatment
and my girl was trying to like defend me
and i was like
bruh this is what he's supposed to do
i'm a comedian i'm nine years older
i'm a stand-up you could be doctor you
know what i mean like he's mad
protective and he's like
don't commit yo you're not getting
another shitty dude i'm be super
protective
i respected yo yo i think they were like
nervous about how he was gonna be
portrayed i was like that guy looks
great
that's a dad i'm telling y'all i know
some of y'all listen to this podcast
maybe it's the first time you listen to
this podcast and it started out a little
crazy
right watch this show it's the best show
in all seriousness i'm obviously joking
around you know i'd love you i think
you're the most amazing
[ __ ] guy in the world but culturally
indians
are so [ __ ] cool we're the best and
i don't think there's been a show that's
showcased cause every time you see
indians like
it's this version and this is typical of
minorities
but it's this version of indians that
white people
it is brown people for white people this
is the most authentically indian show
that i have ever seen that is in english
this bollywood and all that which is
no but it takes place in india and in
america america it's in english it's an
american show takes place in both
and it is dog a lot of like woke brown
people are offended by this show
i loved that this show explains us
without me having to explain
this this is the best way i can look at
it you know how like the jersey shore
exposed a type of italian right that
like
a lot of the world wasn't familiar with
maybe we were because we live in tristan
area right but like a lot of world went
and they're like
yo this is super unique they like do
their eyebrows and their hair but
they're dudes
but they're like really into how they
look like what's going on but they also
fight [ __ ] like what's
happening like
you're just confused by it it has the
same effect
about indians for me like and i probably
know more indians than the average
person yes but i'm still dealing with
you guys as
comics yes right or like friends of you
as a comic right and there is this is no
white people around indians
and there's minutia that like i don't i
was one of the girls on it
hilarious minutia was this [ __ ] yeah
minutiae she was one of them no
absolutely not the one i said is trash
aparna no oh that is a car yeah
yeah there is so many little things that
was minutiae no it's a partner she she
changed
her mom was worse anyway point is
there's little details i don't like
having to explain to everybody like bio
data
it's just like a [ __ ] explanation
this show says what bio that is real
quick and then you see them go through
it
bio data it is when we're when we're
making a match and arrange marriage
it's all your stats essentially you have
this job you
make this much money you are this old
you are this tall or this weight this
skin complexion
the whole the arranged marriage idea is
just who's the most compatible
chemistry is so [ __ ] dumb what are we
wasting our time with that being said
they do go into astrology they do do
some goofy [ __ ]
here's my issue with it and i don't have
a problem with astrology my issue is a
lot of people are offended because
there's one or two things they don't
like
so woke brown people are like oh this
horrifies me that this part of our
culture exists
yo there is a part of everybody's
culture you don't like i don't have to
hate my culture i hate that this thing
comes out i can still love my culture
love the show and be like yeah we can do
better there
son it's so [ __ ] dope they casted it
dope
like there's this one [ __ ] in india
who's like
super progressive for a girl i'm halfway
through i don't know if i've gotten her
yet ankita is her name okay i haven't
gotten her yet
she's like relationships should be 50 50
and like i have my own business i'm a
businesswoman i need to be like
and she does not like the matchmaking
making process she can't connect with
anybody the whole thing
um and her parents you know the parents
are [ __ ] hilarious in it
but the parents are interesting because
her dad goes
she's right yeah but she might be too
ahead of her time
what does that mean she's right that a
woman should be able to have her own
business and she doesn't have to like
succumb to the man in the relationship
and like she didn't have to be taken
care of
she can take care of herself and a man
can take care of himself they could be
together like
she has a very like almost american
perspective on dating
but the father recognizes that that's
gonna make it tricky for her in finding
for finding a husband in india yeah
because they're gonna be certain
cultural expectations of women
so he's literally like yo she's probably
right that being said
society hasn't society's not there yet
baby like get married
you're lonely [ __ ] [ __ ]
please part of my watch watch the show
isn't it like if you notice that about
the people in your society why don't you
like push her to the forefront
like make her more popular instead of
just like accepting the fact that oh
she's too far ahead of her time she's
just somebody she's progressive famous i
mean people can watch the show and form
their own conclusions
but like my sister-in-law comes across
great on the show
as she should but it's like one person
out of 12 we're making matches with on a
reality show where we're gonna go
through
another group of people next year are we
gonna make her the like
she's the spokesperson now for what
society should be and i also think like
bro we progressed a lot in 50 years my
dad this is why i'm gonna defend
us in this show always but like first of
all this is the most i've ever felt
my culture was seen in the show ever
ever mindy kaling everything she does is
brown people for white people
aziz master of none that we all sucked
its dick it is brown people for white
people
that's what it is they clarify what that
is just for people listening yeah it's
like
i just want to say one thing it's like
it's similar to
when you get like um if a white guy
writes the script for a black guy and
it's like this dude who's like hooded
and like walks like this yo yo yo that's
the white
perspective of what a black person is
and this is not to like
i'm not [ __ ] on tiffany hatties
tiffany has mad funny
she is a white person's
perspective of a black woman like white
women
die laughing at tiffany yeah and i won't
speak to tiffany what i will say is when
i see a lot of these shows i'm like yo
you didn't write that for us
you wrote that for white people like
mindy kaling's opening show of her most
recent one
never have i ever it's a girl praying
hindu girl who says what's up gods
ain't no hindu ever gonna say what's up
gods like
right we don't we are polytheistic if
you're hindu but you still say god you
still you know what i mean like it's all
one you know that
this is something that white people can
be like gods also another thing i
noticed is that like
and this is something you never see
indians do
in an indian show indians
code switch crazy
interesting i don't notice so tell me
what no not in a bad way no just i'm
i'm actually curious what did you think
there's an adorable dude on the show
named yasser right he's the [ __ ] best
he's so sweet
but he is the most like hippie granola
like what you think about he's from
texas but he's like you would imagine
him from like [ __ ]
what is it santa cruz dude like wearing
tv sandals whatever like the sweetest
guy the sweetest nerd guy
when he's talking to his mom yeah all of
a sudden his accent is indian
you know cousin's name is anuj if you're
like white you'll say like a nood
you said that [ __ ] properly but like he
was mixing to both
but you don't see that in the show right
in the in like
if you see indians in the show even if
they're talking to them every day say
what i see that with akash every day but
you see him every day yeah but i'm
talking about to see this
on television that's what i'm talking
about it's it's most of these shows are
brown people white people
the best example i can make this is like
when you see gay people on television
it's what straight people's
idea of gay people is will and grace is
not every gay person
right and that's to us it's like that's
gay people that's why rupaul's drag race
apparently pops in the gay community
because gay people are like
finally we're not explaining ourselves
for straight people are we not like
decorating their house or like getting
them an outfit like
i was talking to matteo lane comic about
he was like every show
all we do is we like make white people
look better that's our role for
uh gay people's role it's like oh let me
spruce up your life with like a
fairy godmother that comes around like
sprinkle some dust and now you got a new
couch
exactly boom exactly and he's like
finally it was a show where he was just
like we're not gonna explain what gay is
it'll just be for gay people and that's
what i felt this was that's what i felt
and that's the most fascinating thing
because you're looking at some [ __ ]
it's like every time you go into
chinatown and you look and you're like
oh they're not even
trying to mix it yeah like
they're not trying to make this easy for
nobody they're basically like yo you
want it or not
the [ __ ] is in chinese bruh yeah figure
it out
and maybe people don't generally know
this i just know before
i wasn't really watching the show i knew
my girl was on it we watched it whatever
comics are bashing it brown comics this
is so colorist castus whatever and i
pulled back and i'm like i see that
that is an issue within our culture
however we're coming from
about what that is though colorism and
castism in hinduism there are casts
and the idea was essentially supposed to
be like an assembly line from what i've
read
i'm no expert from what i've read no
cast is better than the other
but at the same time one cast is priests
and the other cast is cleaning up [ __ ]
or whatever
so humans are naturally going to kind of
make it a hierarchy yeah and then
it seeped into society and it really
[ __ ] up a lot of things
right and then so there's like castism
i'm a higher caste than this person
in the show they talk about cast a lot
now also castism exists because it's
like
there is a culture within your cast like
priests have a certain way of living etc
certain things you could eat certain
things you can't eat like
it's almost like yeah you just i get
this person better but to be fair a lot
sorry but to be fair a lot of the girls
that i saw on the show
say like i don't really care what cass
yeah most kids don't the americans
definitely say that
yeah what what what is interesting is
that you don't see cast you do see
people judged by geography
because this is funny though no i'm
curious i haven't gotten there but i
know
i'm all about brown unity etc but i know
if i marry the south indian girl
there's no way in [ __ ] i could
understand her language
like any south indian language to me
it's i'm lost right because there's so
many dialects so
to me that would matter this is more
like oh yeah they're from kolkata not
kolkata
there's good people from kolkata but
like yeah it's just like saying yeah
there's good people from
you know minnesota you know like all
people from minnesota
remember how you explain to me spain has
like catalan or something and yeah the
other regions every region in india
thinks they're catalan
we're the illest yeah you guys are
that's cool you're here but where they
list
but anyway you keep going and colorism
is light skin is very favorable within
our society
every society has their version of
colorism every society has that and it's
[ __ ] up but also
to me it's like yo think about so these
things still exist and that's
we need to work on these things
absolutely but if you think about where
our parents who will have these
judgments are coming from
my dad didn't know he was getting
married until the day he got married
so lit that's crazy even back then most
people
not most a lot of people didn't meet
their wife at all when they got married
so and to be honest it works out about
the same rate as falling in love and
finding somebody about half the
marriages i see are great and about half
armed
but to go from that to hey you choose
whoever you want to choose
and if you can't find somebody i'll help
like the
that's light years of progress in one
generation you understand what i'm
saying like we're not giving our parents
any credit for
how insanely open-minded they are the
only reason my dad is in america
is because his family decided you're
gonna marry this girl in america
he had an ill-ass job lined up in india
and they're like yo [ __ ] that you're
going to america
right and that's it his life changed so
for him to say hey
if you find somebody great i would
prefer she be indian if not that's all
good
if you need help hollering pressure is
so
hilarious bro there's this one mom on
the show
and the kid won't has turned down like a
hundred different chicks
yeah and the mom kid is gorgeous though
no no this is a different one i'm
talking about yeah this one's all right
and uh the mom starts taking her blood
pressure
in front of him and showing him the
blood pressure
and going and going look what you're
doing to me
you see my blood pressure is so high
because we have a wedding to plan and
you don't have a wife
because they choose the date and then
they choose the girl
wait really so this [ __ ] is hilarious or
this is just for the show in hinduism
astrology how do you choose the venue
with
more like discretion than you choose to
wife like we're getting married here
figure it out you got until august the
date is a big deal and i'm surprised you
can do that without because you
i had to match my star chart my parents
wanted to know what time and where my
girl was born
so they can make sure we're compatible
yeah yeah that's not if we weren't
compatible they'd have been like yo
what can we do to make this more
compatible but they're not going to say
find a different wife yeah
they have found like little ways around
whatever because astrology is a huge
thing in hinduism but find different
ways around her like
culturally not religiously just like um
so my girl and i had a
there are favorable days to get married
we had a hindu wedding ceremony in may
because on that date according to the
hindu calendar this is a favorable time
to get married no i didn't get invited
to your hindu weddings
oh [ __ ] so you're like married married
after this weekend i remember that yeah
i remember that but you didn't invite me
you just said it was happening you
didn't say you want to be there i got to
say i want to be at my friend's hindu
wedding
but i thought it was is mainly for your
wife's
family so it's for my family my wife is
like she's sick and in sicky they're
like yo we don't care about like
dave we are actively this is the one we
were supposed to we were supposed to go
to this one you're not gonna invite us
to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow son no this ain't a wedding this is
no no
no no no no no no no don't get all
wriggled out of the neighborhood
i want to go to the favorable date yeah
this is the thing you believe in more
than anything in the world don't you
this your religion is it not it's thing
most
this is more cultural than religious i
don't give a [ __ ] so
marriage is cultural i'ma be honest i
don't think there was any non-indians
invited
what is that supposed to mean i didn't
want you all there i respect it yo
that's
foul bro i don't want to explain again i
don't like explaining i don't explain
hey it's a favorable date in hinduism
so we're going to do it on this day
doing it now i know because you're
making me i'm not making you explain the
[ __ ] hinduism
yeah making you explain the friendship
part are you not gonna have me at your
wedding bro
bruh i want this to be a happy day for
my wife
[Music]
it's your wedding not her she don't even
believe in this [ __ ]
the least i can do is make her happy for
your [ __ ] you think she gives a listen
i wanted to be at that part of the
wedding more than she did you think
you're gonna want to be at a zoom
wedding
i was gonna zoom in with my full outfit
you ain't even got i
came all over instead of myself
you